yahiko Sanko faces quite a challenge
trying to help Germans understand the
political complexities of his home
country The Gambia even he is confused
by the current turn of events in his
West African home and after 22 years of
dictatorship the Gambian seemed ready to
give democracy another try
we feel like the German people will feel
like to know how is that possible and
and fatah gosh you know and what I the
expectation of the Gambian terrific is
right now in JAMA in The Gambia Sanko
was a history teacher who spoke too much
about the dangers of dictatorships in
his lessons too much for the regime that
is he says he was arrested tortured and
locked up he decided to flee when he had
the chance he's been waiting in Germany
for half a year to see if his
application for asylum will be granted
he learns German in his spare time and
tries to regain the hope he lost on his
treacherous trip to Europe - because we
aren't able to see each other soon they
just have to hit each other boom so some
of our friends lose their legs they are
instantly broken you just kind of just
imagine it in a 17 of them die and we
have to bear them in 8 days a lot of
people die in the desert Sanko is
responsible for maintenance at his
refugee shelter he says that at least
this way he feels useful almost all of
the other migrants at his shelter are
also Gambians and most of them are
dealing with the same range of emotions
they're tracking with unease what it
once looked like a move toward democracy
back home at the same time they see it
as highly likely they will be deported
from Germany they put it to us that we
have a little peasant to live here now
asylum procedure is only 3% which
definitely is not a good sign but with
all this I still believe in myself
yahiko Sanko rarely leaves the refugee
shelter except sometimes to go to the
mosque for Friday prayers he says he's
grateful to the Germans for having taken
him in
but sometimes he worries when he hears
in the media about right-wing populists
when we watch situations like this we
felt bad with ourselves because it's
kind of racism to us you know we are we
had just the same human being you know
different color the only different is
call up some good news for Sanko he's
been reunited with his family once again
following months of hope and fear they
were separated while on the run in Libya
and now all three lived together at the
refugee shelter in Heidelberg